meine Damen und Herren
dieser 24 februar ist ein furchtbarer
Tag für die Ukraine und ein düsterer Tag
für Europa
mit seinem Angriff auf die Ukraine
bricht der russische Präsident Putin
abermals eklatant das Völkerrecht
Putin bringt damit Leid und Zerstörung
über seine direkten Nachbarn
er verletzt die Souveränität und die
Grenzen der Ukraine
er gefährdet das Leben von unzähligen
unschuldigen in der Ukraine dem Bruder
Volk Russlands
herzlich stellt er damit auch die
Friedensordnung unseres Kontinents in
Frage
für all das gibt es keine Rechtfertigung
das ist putinskrieg
ich habe dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski heute früh in einem Telefonat
gesagt in diesem schweren Stunden gilt
die Ukraine und gilt ihr und ihren
Bürgern und Bürgern unsere volle
Solidarität
angesichts der aktuellen Entwicklung
habe ich heute Vormittag das
Sicherheitskabinett einberufen damit die
Regierung über die Lage berät und über
das weitere Vorgehen gemeinsam
entscheidet
alle Bundesbürger die noch im Land sind
bitte ich aber mal sehr dringend die
Ukraine zu verlassen zu ihrem eigenen
Schutz
die Präsidentin des Deutschen
Bundestages habe ich gebeten für Sonntag
eine Sondersitzung des Bundestages
einzuberufen dort werde ich eine
Regierungserklärung abgeben
als Vorsitzender der G7 werde ich mich
heute Nachmittag in einer Videokonferenz
der G7 Staats- und Regierungschefs für
eine einheitliche und klare Reaktion der
wirtschaftlich stärksten Demokratien der
Welt einsetzen
als nächsten Schritt werden wir in enger
Absprache mit unseren internationalen
Partnern in der NATO und in der
Europäischen Union noch heute weitere
harte Sanktionen gegen Russland
beschließen es ist gut dass wir das
sorgfältig vorbereitet haben
Ziel der Sanktionen ist es der
russischen Führung klar zu machen für
diese Aggression zahlt sie einen
bitteren Preis
es wird sich zeigen
Putin hat mit seinem Krieg einen
schweren Fehler begangen
lass es mich noch ein Wort an unseren
NATO Verbündeten in Osteuropa in Polen
in Rumänien im Baltikum richten ich
möchte ihn ausdrücklich versichern wir
verstehen eure Sorgen im Angesicht
dieser Entwicklung nur zu gut wir werden
euch zur Seite stehen Deutschland steht
zur Beistandspflicht der NATO
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
Präsidenten schlage ich vor dass sich
die Staats- und Regierungschefs der
NATO-Staaten sehr bald in Präsenz
treffen um die Lage zu erörtern
heute Abend werde ich nach Brüssel
fahren um dort im Kreise der Staats- und
Regierungschefs der Europäischen Union
das weitere Vorgehen zu besprechen die
Lage ist sehr ernst
Russlands Präsidenten Putin möchte ich
dazu aufrufen den militärischen Angriff
sofort zu stoppen
den Blutvergießen
Einheit zu gebieten und seine Truppen
vom Territorium der Ukraine vollständig
zurückzuziehen
vielen Dank